por primera vez de una gran dejó
entrever que habrá un nuevo gobierno
pero sigue sin reconocer su derrota el
presidente saliente en su primera
declaración desde que se confirmó a job
hay de andrés intelecto planteó esa
posibilidad pero sin hacer ninguna
mención a las elecciones y lo hizo
mientras hablaba de los avances frente a
una vacuna contra el cob y 19 en
momentos donde el país está sumido en
ricos diarios de casos desde hace 10
días
esta administración no irá a un
confinamiento pase lo que pase en el
futuro quién sabe qué administración
será supongo que el tiempo lo dirá pero
puedo decirles que esta administración
no irá al confinamiento eso es lo más
cerca que ha estado hasta ahora el
mandatario de reconocer la derrota en
efecto desde las elecciones del 3 de
noviembre hecho en va ha persistido con
acusaciones sin pruebas de fraude
electoral generalizado se limitó a
destacar lo bien que en su opinión actúa
su administración en la gestión de la
pandemia también amenazó con no
distribuir los primeros lotes de esta
vacuna a nueva york- por su gobernador
grata al grupo como quien se ha mostrado
resistente a cualquier vacuna que no sea
aprobada por las autoridades sanitarias
del estado así que el gobierno como
tendrá que avisarnos cuando esté listo
es web
wicked wicked de lo contrario no podemos
entregarla a un estado que no la va a
dar a su gente inmediatamente
trampa acabó su declaración sin aceptar
preguntas de los medios de comunicación